here Masek and thank you so much for
being with us for viewers who might not
know exactly who you are how would you
describe yourself what's your job do you
see I'm an Israeli writer speaker I'm
speaking on campuses and communities
around the world I also do social media
for for living but my my passion what
I'm really doing for that keeps me going
is advocating for a freezer for my
country
you yourself served that five years I
think it was yeah with Israeli Defense
Force um obviously everyone does their
national service what was it that made
you think you know I want to keep going
I felt like my military service really
was was meaningful I was able to work
with Palestinians in the West Bank I
served in Hebron Jerusalem and Ramallah
and I really started like you know I
made a difference that my position was
to be the humanitarian officer in those
regions but did you watch both flops
working in the potato in the West Bank I
mean did you do you understand why the
was just immediate very obvious
antipathy coming from the Palestinians
definitely I mean we can't ignore the
fact that there's a military control
over the West Bank of another country
it's not Palestinian security at least
in Area C 52% of the West Bank is still
under control by when Israeli military
so I totally understand I would hate it
just as much how does it feel to point a
gun at your fellow man it's not nice
it's not a good feeling just I mean I
was 18 19 20 and to the the fact that
you hold a gun is something that is so
unnatural and when I joined the Army I
was very I was really a peacenik I
thought that that's why I ended up in
the human pterin unit I thought that I'm
going to go there and just do peace and
then they gave me this gun and it was
it's not it's not the most comfortable
feeling it's it's scary but but when
you're in a situation like this when
your life is being threatened when
you're two hours away from your home and
you know that your my cousin's my baby
cousins are there and if I won't hold my
weapon and protect the border will be it
will be them and I think that's a big
difference between these Ray
the army to any other armies two armies
that are sending their weapons you know
thousands of miles and kilometers over
c2 to fight for oil or for democracy or
for ideas at the end of the day the
Israeli army I mean what we're doing is
defending our home defending our borders
we're not going to to Afghanistan or to
Iraq or to anywhere like this I mean you
mentioned you mentioned earlier your
identity and part of that obviously is
that you are like you're a gay man I
don't know whether I should have been as
surprised as I was but it did kind of
slightly strike me as in Congress that
you you actually came out crossed whilst
in the IDF and to to your commanding you
clear out the closet just tell me about
that it's a funny story I mean I was in
the closet I never spoke to anyone about
it that was 18 and my family would I
thought back then would never accept it
there Iraqi Tunisia and very traditional
and my commander back then he was an
awesome guy it was 32 and I was 18 and I
told him that my best friend just came
out of the closet my best friend was
also in the army
and I remember my commanders sitting
there and saying well there's something
else that bothers you right and I'm
saying what he says well I think you're
gay too right
so there I am not not being helped out
of the closet being pulled out of the
closet by my commander but it was such a
relief to hear someone saying it and
then I remember saying yes and he said
well there's another thing I think you
have a crush on your on your best friend
which he was also right about right I
mean you mentioned it as well but but
but another key bash man I imagined to
be key aspect of your identities that
have being Mizrahi Jew and the fact that
you moved to Israel from from Iraq again
tell us about this because it's
fascinating this that Kennedy Arabic in
the Jewish coming together in one right
well my family came to Israel my mom
came from Iraq in 1951 and my dad came
from Tunisia yeah it's a big
misconception I think that we're seeing
that I'm seeing around the world that
people think that Israel is this white
or European country when 60% of Israeli
Jews are Jews from the Middle East in
North Africa
so they came to Israel they came with an
identity and culture that was Arabic
culture into this country that is newly
born and being
tagged by Arab countries and they have
this conflict of identity win between
being you know appreciating Arabic
culture and enjoying still cooking Arab
food and and still listening to Arabic
music in this country that speaks Hebrew
that has been attacked by Arab countries
around us and I think that was a big
part of them developing in today's
already society and creating this new
Israeli identity
did you experience any of that that
tension we're growing up definitely and
it's funny a lot of times when I'm
speaking about it I'm worried that it
will be used to to say Israelis a racist
country I don't think Israel is racist
but I think that there is racism in
Israel just like in every society but I
felt that a lot growing up I remember
one when my teacher in in high school
was was asking us about our favorite
music and I mentioned Uncle Tom is my
favorite singer Egyptian singer and my
teacher started laughing and I said oh
those miss Rockets they have they have
no culture she was a European to just
just described his done-for-you
experience of growing up in a part of
the world where there is let's be honest
about it an ever-present risk of
violence yeah it's you don't really wake
up in the morning and think that your
life is in danger it's this something
that is in the back of your of your mind
that you walk around with it knowing
that there might be something happening
there might be a terror attack I
experienced a Rhodes terror attacks in
my life where I was close or almost
inside a terror in situation of we've
just you just glossed over that well
I've been involved in some terrorist
attacks I mean just a little bit about
that because you know the majority the
overwhelming majority people in this
country haven't even been close to a gun
yeah it's interesting that I just jumped
over it but but it's true I mean I think
Israelis are like that I when I was 12
it was the closest that I got into
terror attack I was about to get into an
ice-cream shop when Nadia scoop shot
blew up and I was thrown back and the
terrorists walked inside
blew himself up killing a grandmother
and her two-year-old granddaughter
was shocking for me it was the first
time I think that I was that close to
and the only time that was that close to
two that's sitting here today with you
what did you think of the Palestinians
that day I was really angry I was really
angry the things that ran through my
head were really racist and I remember
going back home and and my mom was
crying and she hugged me and she said
you're alive you're alive she kept on
screaming you're alive you're alive
you're alive and I think that this
really changed my perception that I was
really angry and my mom instead of
tongue yes you should be angry or what
she almost lost her son and she's just
focusing on the fact that I'm alive and
I think since then really my perception
really changed and that's what it would
let me at the end to join the military
unit to want to do something to to
achieve peace um I'm not willing to
accept the reality of bloodshed and I
don't want better for my kids and for
Palestinian kids I just want take you
back to UCL and you'll you will remember
the sonship and just in case let's take
a look at the clip
he did not notice
I saw you watching that in a shake of
your hair yeah I got goose bumps tell us
what it was like I was terrifying it was
terrifying I mean I'm coming to a campus
and I'm I wasn't scared for my life I
was scared for the students that were
with me the Jewish student there was 10
or 12 to students with me in this room
and then people started jumping into the
room and banging on the doors I thought
they're going to bring down the doors
and I was there and I'm you know a
citizen of Israel in the UK in Europe it
locked in a room where with people
banging on the doors saying you know
calling shame shame shame trying to get
to us to me and group of Jewish students
it's it's disturbing it's more than
disturbing it's it's awful thing I mean
I don't want to minimize your
experiences of that but I kind of want
to take us back to where we were earlier
in the interview I said do you not
understand why people are so angry not
not that hungry I mean I would
understand if they if you told me you
know here in England would protest
against everyone against Russia against
Chinese against Iranian any one of the
57 Arab Muslim countries against Qatar
and Saudi Arabia against speakers from
all over the world against Americans
because let's sit let's face it I mean
every country has its problems but it
sounds like that and just because I'm
Israeli I mean it's not it's not because
I'm some because of any part of my
identity ok sure maybe because I served
in the army but every threat most
Israelis serve in the army it's
compulsory service so to send it's
because I served in the army so you're
basically saying any Israeli is a target
any Israeli is a fair target and they
don't deserve to speak on campuses they
don't deserve to to voice their opinion
while people like Medina dad was invited
to speak at Columbia without any protest
as you mentioned your sexuality again
you mentioned the kind of the acceptance
of trans rights I mean do you think do
you find it slightly strange given that
I left here in the UK and elsewhere well
in essence the driving force behind gay
rights that they are now so critical of
the only part of the Middle East in
which there are gay rights
yeah I think instead of supporting them
instead of supporting us the LGBTQ
community in Israel we are being
attacked and I'm being attacked a lot of
times by my my own community by LGBTQ
people around the world and that's it's
really I mean it's awful and there's
this term pinkwashing that Israel gave
gay rights to protect itself from
opening or washing yourself yeah many
times and I think it's it's ridiculous
for LGBTQ people to accuse me in pink
washing and saying because I'm queer I'm
going to you know to cancel anything
you're saying because you can't
represent Israel with all its crimes and
promote it as a gay person but I mean
they're accusing me and what they are
doing they are using their queer
identity to fight for political cause if
you are fighting for LGBTQ rights let's
speak about LGBTQ rights and speak about
force transgender operations in Iran
where it's the country with the highest
transgender operation not willingly
people are told that your if you're gay
you're either gonna die are going to go
through an operation or in Egypt the
highest of amount of operation of women
to men because women can be lesbian or
are in Gaza in the Gaza Strip where gay
men are being thrown out of rooftops
that's we need to speak about those
issues and no one is speaking about it
do you think those actions are justified
by the Koran I don't like to get into it
I don't think that a Koran I mean if you
look at the Bible there's also things in
the Bible that are not really started on
shellfish exactly so I don't I don't
think that it's did its base on everyone
have their interpretation I think that
Islam is is evolving and we're seeing
voices of change in many my many Muslims
around the world but it's not about
Islam it's about those countries that
that are oppressive and homophobic
anti-semitism is obviously been
something we've talked about in the UK a
lot of late the Labour Party in its and
its travails that the Eva definition of
anti-semitism but before we get kind of
get into that it is it possible to be
critical of the State of Israel without
without being accused of anti-semitism
I've been I've been criticizing Israel
since we started now
I hope people don't think definitely
there is and and there's actually the
the international Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance define what criticism of Israel
and legitimate criticism is as long as
you criticize Israel
just like you criticize any other
country as long as you criticize Israel
without opposing its existence which I
can't even believe that we need to
discuss about discuss the the idea of if
a country has right to exist why why is
that even an issue I never heard anyone
say you know that's that's the UK has
the right to exist I mean is
anti-semitism still a problem yeah it's
definitely a problem I don't think that
anyone that Chris has it I don't think
that the majority of people that
criticize Israel are anti-semite I don't
even think that many of the people that
support boycotting Israel are
anti-semite they might be pret they're
they're part of a group or of a movement
that I think in large is anti-semitic
the leadership is anti-semitic but I
don't think many of the people that
boycott Israel they don't even
understand that and that's what I'm
trying to do I'm trying to educate
people and to help them understand what
is anti-semitic anti-semitism it hasn't
passed from the world it's it's still
alive it's as you said it's it's alive
with the with with Jeremy Corbyn in the
Labor Party where 85% of our UK Jews
think that he is anti-semitic I heard
that the labor wanted to redefine
anti-semitism for the Jewish for the
British Jews that will not happen with
LGBTQ community there will be an outrage
if anyone would say you know gay people
don't understand one or more phobias let
us tell you what I want phobia is or
racism or turn black the black community
you know what maybe you're a bit
paranoid maybe you don't really know
what what's racism against you again you
know I would never sit with a black
person and tell them you don't really
understand what it what what racism is
against you or there are some things
that you are a bit overreacting about
it's it's I don't think that anyone
should do that and if a community but
you know and enlarge not not only in the
UK all over the world I mean the vast
majority of Jews around the world are
Zionists it's saying that you know we
believe that this levels of criticism is
under sermon anti-semitic
I think the word should listen and it's
important because we've seen where we're
not listening led us in the past where
do you think that
this rise in anti-semitism is coming
from on the political spectrum you know
the left or the right definitely the
right far right I was saying it in
Europe were saying it in the u.s. we're
in Pittsburgh there they an outright
person walks into us into a synagogue
and shot Jews that were praying
so definitely they're the strongest and
the most violent type of anti-semitism
comes from doubt right the radical right
I think the very dangerous type of
anti-semitism as we said before comes
from the left because the left the
radical left is supposed to be about
human rights and this type of
anti-semitism is is under a facade that
of human rights of equality of fighting
for a political cause or in the Middle
East and that's what makes it even more
dangerous because I can tell you who was
a Nazi I can tell you who's a KKK and I
see them online you know they call me
the most the worst names but when
someone says well you know any Zionist
that that kills Palestinians should or
that is against Palestinians should not
be humanized like a feminist leader said
in the past recently then it's more it's
more dangerous that's what I think are
you emotional agent several people have
suggested maybe you have to kill me
I've never killed anyone and that's yet
in my job with the Mossad but no no I'm
not a messiah a Mossad agent and you
have it you have it first we had a year
first right hand magic thanks very much
for joining me